zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
am sonntag wählt deutschlands
drittgrößtes bundestag bundesland
nämlich baden württemberg einen neuen
landtag
und das wird besonders spannend im
hinblick auf die bundestagswahl
wie schneiden die grünen ab wie sehr
schadet das masken gate der union und
vor allem welche themen interessieren in
diesem jahr die wählerinnen und wähler
wir wollen uns das gemeinsam mit ihnen
und euch zu hause anschauen und mit
diesen beiden hier meine eigenen
probleme wenn nicht bürgerlich heißt
koste lukas staier stammt aus haslach im
idyllischen kinzigtal und ist
realschullehrer
doch anders als andere schwarzwald buben
ist kosten schwarz die schwierigkeiten
die er dadurch bekommt thematisierte
rapper in seiner musik und nimmt
neuerdings auch in kurzen clips den
dialekt seiner heimat auf die schippe
wie bei diesem fiktiven besuch beim
konservativen schwiegervater
[Musik]
ein weiterer social media hit aus dem
ländle sind die videos von free kickers
hier treten die macher in verschiedenen
disziplinen gegeneinander an und holten
damit unter anderem den goldene kamera
digital award
einer von ihnen martin luther aus
rastatt bei karlsruhe
wenn er nicht klickt studiert er online
medien management die digitalisierung
von schulen und studiengebühren gehören
zu den themen die ihn vor der wahl
interessieren
martin und cosmo zwei bieler die fragen
haben herzlich willkommen lukas staier
alias coco und martin luzie schön dass
ihr dabei seid falls die userinnen und
user zu hause irritiert sind wir duzen
uns heute einfach alle komplett und wer
sich zu hause jetzt wieder auf die füße
getreten fühlt weil er genutzt wird wenn
du zu uns einfach alle also ich freue
mich auf eure kommentare und welche
einschätzungen ihr zu dieser
landtagswahl habt und ich freue mich
natürlich auch auf eure kommentare und
fragen an die beiden wie immer in die
kommentare oder wenn ihr die heute app
nutzt die zeit heute apps bitte diese e
mail adresse nutzen wir holen später
noch jemanden dazu nämlich unseren zdf
reporter simon 20 aus dem landesstudio
mit ein bisschen expertise zum
landtagswahlkampf
und um diese sachen geht es in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
geht es am sonntag los das mit spannung
erwartete superwahljahr 20 21 in
stuttgart liegt der grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann
laut jüngsten politbarometer deutlich
vor der cdu der droht mit ihrer
spitzenkandidatin eisenmann eine
historische niederlage
doch wer gewinnt wer verliert
tatsächlich die korona krise macht die
wahlen so spannend wie nie vela müssen
mit abstand überzeugt werden
wahlveranstaltung waren dann ins netz
und das virus selbst wird zum
dominierenden thema nächste station
sachsen anhalt
hier gibt es im juni einen weiteren
fingerzeig für das große finale
das findet am 26 september statt wenn
die bürger nicht nur in drei weiteren
bundesländern ihre kreuze machen sollen
sondern in ganz deutschland ausgang
offen und überraschungen nicht
ausgeschlossen
nur eins ist klar angela merkel will
nach 16 jahren als kanzlerin schluss
machen
das ist tatsächlich so ziemlich das
einzige was wir sagen können was
definitiv im herbst anders sein wird
angela merkel wird nicht mehr
bundeskanzlerin sein zumindest mit blick
von heute ihr beiden frage zum einstieg
wer wird die nächste bundeskanzlerin
armin laschet markus söder olaf scholz
oder annalena baerbock koslow wenn du
anfangen möchte ich glaube das hat sich
in den letzten monaten hat das ein
bisschen gewechselt gefühlt mal war der
vorne mal war der vorne aber wenn ich
jetzt tippen sollte was ist irgendwie so
in meinem kopf hatte ist der süder der
zumindest für die union als
kanzlerkandidat ins rennen geht genau da
müssen wir noch gucken ob es überhaupt
wird ja sagen viele politikexperten auch
martin was meinst du auf den tipps du
wer wird der nächste kanzler die nächste
kanzlerin direkt die erste frage wo ich
schon das ist auch überhaupt nicht
schlimm denn auch da geht's dir wie
vielen anderen politikexperten die reden
zwar immer viel haben aber am ende auch
nicht so viel mehr ahnung weil
tatsächlich echt noch ganz vieles offen
ist wir wissen zum beispiel auch nicht
welche themen eine rolle spielen werden
was aber klar ist dass digitale diese
digitalisierung eine große rolle spielt
digitale formate weil es einfach nicht
so ist wie in anderen wahlkämpfen dass
man auf dem marktplatz geht um große
reden hält viele formate haben sich ins
netz verlagert auch jetzt schon in den
bundestagswahl kämpfen in den
landtagswahlkämpfen und umso wichtiger
ist es dass es digitale formate gibt um
sich eine politische meinung zu bilden
wie zum beispiel den wahlomat den klickt
ihr heute abend dankenswerterweise mit
euch durch und wir mit uns durch und wir
erklären aber kurz wie es geht den
wahlomat gibt es schon seit 2002
bereitgestellt von der bundeszentrale
für politische bildung
auch jetzt wieder für die landtagswahlen
in rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
insgesamt 38 thesen kann man hier etwa
zustimmen oder ablehnen und so
herausfinden mit welcher partei die
eigene meinung am ehesten übereinstimmt
ausgewählt hat die thesen ein team aus
20 bis 25 jungen wähler innen
politikwissenschaftler innen und anderen
expertinnen es geht um themen wie arbeit
familie bildung oder umwelt den parteien
wurden die thesen zugeschickt sie haben
ihre jeweilige zustimmung oder ablehnung
begründet und so können am ende die
positionen der parteien miteinander
verglichen werden etwa drei wochen vor
einer wahl wird der jeweilige wahlomat
online gestellt und wir machen das heute
abend hier zusammen ihr können zu hause
natürlich auch sehr gerne mitmachen den
wahlomat findet kann man ganz einfach
über die suchmaschine eures vertrauens
und dann könnt ihr auch eure haltungen
zu verschiedenen positionen überprüfen
und abgleichen mit den parteien
ich werde mich hier auch durchklicken
ihr könnt das in eurem tempo machen aber
ich komme immer wieder mal mit fragen zu
euch die wir gerne mit euch zu sprechen
würden und ich würde sagen wir fangen
mal gemeinsam an und beginnen mit frage
1 hier ist schon mal frage 2 aber wir
wollen mit frage eins anfangen
die lautet das land soll allen
schülerinnen und schülern kostenlos
digitale endgeräte zur verfügung stellen
martin oder cossu wer will von euch
zuerst antworten was es eure haltung
stimmt ihr dazu oder stimmt ihr dann
nicht zu und wenn ja warum
martin wir sehen da kannst du gerade
noch mal anfangen gern den anfang
verpasst und dich noch nicht gehört hört
man mich ja wunderbar jetzt klebe
wunderbar ich nehme mir einfach mal kurz
den anfang raus und ich habe da ganz
klar zugestimmt gerade jetzt wo auch
noch alles im homeschooling ist denke
ich ist es extrem wichtig dass da auch
kinder die jetzt irgendwie auch sozial
schwächeren familien kommen da nicht
benachteiligt werden gegenüber den
anderen mitschülern
deswegen fand ich das auf jeden fall
eine sehr gute sache und auch nicht nur
im homeschooling sondern auch in der
schule denke ich wird es immer wichtiger
dass kinder mit ihrer mobilen geräten
vertraut gemacht werden
deswegen gibt es ein ganz klares jahr
von mir kannst du es gibt wahrscheinlich
kaum jemanden der sagt nee digitale
endgeräte für kinder finde ich doof muss
man noch mal mit den parteien am ende
abgleichen aber was ist deine meinung ja
dann ja ich stimme auf jeden fall zu ich
finde dich fragen insgesamt oder die
frage gibt und sich so ein bisschen
schwierig stellt auch weil ist es so
einfach dass man sagt gut die kriegen
das ist alle oder geht es dann wirklich
auch wieder um ausgewählte schulen um
ausgewählte klasse mit wirklich darum
geht dass jeder schüler ein endgerät
krieg trennt sich natürlich gut ich bin
ja aktuell auch an der schule und
arbeitete und finde dass wie auch martin
das gesagt hat dass da soziale
ungleichheiten einfach nur viel zu große
rolle spielen dass kinder hat die so ein
macbook oder was auch immer zu hause
haben einfach dann weiter kommen und die
die sowieso schon benachteiligt sind
die hängen werden weiter abgehängt und
das kann nicht sein
die kritik die du da gerade geäußert
hast am wallufer teilen viele auch in
der community und sagen die fragen sind
teilweise so dass sie komplexe sachen
beschreiben und die muss man dann aber
mit ja oder nein beantworten und das
kann man eigentlich gar nicht nur leon
hanke schreibt zum beispiel über youtube
ich habe den wahlomat gemacht bei mir
kamen cdu und fdp raus aber ganz ehrlich
ich finde aus 38 fragen kann man seine
wahl nicht entscheiden das natürlich
auch ein punkt weil auch gar nicht alle
themen abgedeckt werden in den 38 fragen
und auch die parteien differenzieren da
tatsächlich in ihren antworten also
viele sind tatsächlich dafür diese
digitalen endgeräte zu verteilen
aber in der finanzierung so wie du es
gerade angesprochen hast da gehen die
meinungen sehr auseinander die fdp zum
beispiel sagt ja aber die familien
sollen es selber bezahlen und kriegen
dann halt einen zuschuss vom land jetzt
muss ich ihr könnt euch selber klicken
aber ich sage jetzt mal du würdest
trotzdem zustimmen oder kann ich kann
ich hier für euch beide ein jahr bei
frage 1 million geben ja also wenn man
unsere durch sich natürlich alles klar
martin hat schon zugestimmt
dann wären wir bei frage 2 die
verbrennungsmotoren baden württemberg
ist ja ein autoland die frage ist baden
württemberg soll sich dafür einsetzen
dass halb 2035 keine autos mit
verbrennungsmotor mehr zugelassen werden
dürfen was meint ihr dazu
also es gibt ja auch das
klimaschutzabkommen und grundsätzlich
ist es eine gute idee
die autos nicht mehr so lange fahren zu
lassen mit verbrennungsmotoren nur die
frage ist und da bin ich halt auch zu
wenig im thema drin um entscheiden zu
können können wir das 2035 schon
erreichen sind wir überhaupt
wissenschaftlich schon so weit dass wir
andere fahrzeuge dann auf die straße
bringt grundsätzlich würde ich sagen ja
weil das geht ums klima es geht um die
umwelt ob das umsetzbar ist kann ich
jetzt als laie auch schwer entscheiden
martin was sagst du ja ich bin
tatsächlich auch kein experte ich habe
mich versucht auch ein bisschen schlau
zu machen ich habe auch da griechen wie
das mit anderen ländern sind und die die
haben schon ziele von 2025 bis 2030 und
gerade im aspekt form vom klimaschutz
ist es denke ich extrem wichtig und ob
es auch erreicht werden kann bis 22.35
ist natürlich schwierig zu sagen aber
ich denke wenn man sich so ein ziel
setzt arbeitet man auch viel
zielgerichteter daraufhin und wenn man
es jetzt 23 jahre später vielleicht
erreicht ist es denke ich trotzdem
vielleicht früher als wenn man sich eben
kein limit gesetzt hat also würde ich
bei euch beiden wenn ich euch richtig
verstehe 1 stimme zu antippen okay das
ist in baden württemberg insofern
interessant weil die grünen also die
partei von herrn kretschmann auf
bundesebene gesagt haben wir wollen 20
30 raus aus den verbrennungsmotoren
er hat da selber gesagt moment
moment moment und wie er da jetzt raus
kommt das wird in der tat eine spannende
frage wie das weitergeht also ich stimme
hier für euch mal zu und die nächsten
thesen würde ich einfach mal kühn
überspringen weil wir wie gesagt nicht
alle 38 durchgehen können aber ich hätte
noch eine auto frage nämlich frage 7 auf
allen autobahnen in baden württemberg
soll ein generelles tempolimit gelten
wenn habe ich jetzt da als
gesprächspartner zwei junge männer die
sagen ich habe gar kein auto weil ich
brauche keines oder zwei die sagen war
also richtig schnell über die autobahn
fahren
dafür liebe ich deutschland dass es kein
tempolimit gibt tatsächlich habe ich
mein auto zu hause gelassen ich bin
jetzt nach stuttgart gezogen für mein
studium und hier brauche ich definitiv
kein auto das ist alles sehr gut
vernetzt dass ich es auch so erreichen
kann
andererseits ist es natürlich auch so
eine art lebensgefühl auf der autobahn
mal bisschen stärker auf die tube zu
drücken und gehört schon passt er zur
deutschen kultur deswegen den ich bei
dem thema echt ein bisschen gespalten
natürlich gibt es auch den aspekt vom
klimaschutz aber da weiß ich jetzt nicht
ob es jetzt zum beispiel in den anderen
ländern großes tempo limits eben gibt
auch den autobahn
ob es dann wirklich zu einer
signifikanten änderungen hinaus gelaufen
ist quasi dass da wirklich so viel
eingespart werden konnte hier fragt
übrigens gerade 21 unterstrich 11 über
youtube kann man auch martin wählen
kratzen schon fans vielleicht gibt's ja
sehen gedanken über einen wechsel in die
politik auf jeden fall kommt das kommt
dass hier sehr gut an in der community
und afrikas sind groß vertreten das
freut uns natürlich sehr
kosovo ist das mit dir und dem thema
auto also mehr als jemand der ein auto
besitzt aber das wird nicht wirklich
schneller als 130 was für mich auch voll
in ordnung ist weil ich tatsächlich er
das also ich bin dafür für das
tempolimit einfach weil ich auch so was
autos angeht auch so ein bisschen
gebrandmarkt das kind bin
history bedingt einfach den unfällen und
ich finds halt also man kennt das ja die
ganzen raser auf den autobahnen ist halt
manchmal
ich finde es okay wenn man mal 100 stück
62 fällt aber wenn dann eine
vorbeirauschen mit 250 km h und du
denkst dann muss jetzt nur irgendwie
jemand kurz nach links ausscheren und
der eine reagiert zu spät
ich finde es einfach mehr gefährlich und
auch in hinsicht auf das klima macht es
schon sinn ich weiß dass ich da ziemlich
allein bin auch in baden württemberg
aber für mich macht das ist tatsächlich
also für mich wird es keinen unterschied
machen und ich wäre dafür okay dann sag
ich an der stelle schon mal danke und
bitte euch einfach so ein bisschen
weiter durchzuklicken und euch die
fragen anzugucken und eure haltung dazu
einzunehmen und wechseln mal rüber ins
landesstudio nach stuttgart zu unserem
zdf-reporter 27 simon danke dass du
dabei bist ja wie ist denn wo wir gerade
beim thema klima sind das fazit des
grünen ministerpräsidenten kretschmann
und seiner regierung in
baden-württemberg in sachen klima ich
glaube es ist eine gemischte bilanz und
es ist eine frage der sich kretschmann
immer wieder konfrontiert sieht nämlich
die frage wie grün ist eigentlich dieser
erste grüne ministerpräsident wenn man
es zum beispiel guckt wie sie es mit
erneuerbaren energien aus
gibt es durchaus keine wahnsinnig gute
bilanz da hängt man hinter anderen
bundesländern hinterher und ist nicht da
wo man es eigentlich erwarten könnte
nach zehn jahre grünen-regierungschef
besser sie zum beispiel aus bei
ladesäulen da geht's in baden
württemberg im vergleich zu anderen
bundesländern ein ganz gutes netz aber
diese klimafrage ist natürlich ja ein
kleiner knackpunkt für herrn kretschmann
würde ich sagen und das hat sich auch
eine gegenbewegung gegründet die klima
liste hier in baden württemberg die auch
zur landtagswahl antritt und bislang
sehen wir dann noch keine verschiebungen
dass die jetzt den grünen massiv stimmen
wegnehmen würden aber das liegt
vermutlich auch daran dass corona in
diesem wahlkampf das entscheidende thema
war genau du sprichst es an das
politbarometer hat abgefragt was sind
denn die wichtigsten probleme in baden
württemberg und wir können das hier mal
zeigen die zahlen sind von letzter woche
und da ist ganz klar 66 prozent sagen
die korona krise ist das größte problem
das wir haben
das zweitgrößte ist umwelt und energie
wende aber halt mit einem riesen abstand
21 prozent dann kommen bildung und
schule mit 14
und dann kommen wirtschaft und
konjunktur mit zehn prozent wobei man
auch das ja von corona eigentlich gar
nicht so richtig trennen kann
simon welche rolle hat denn das thema
klimaschutz im wahlkampf gespielt
im grunde so wie das jetzt auch wir sind
bei diesen zahlen durchkamen
wenn wir umfragen auf der straße gemacht
haben und die menschen gefragt haben
welche themen sind für euch für sie
interessant dann war das eigentlich
immer corona und all diese themen die
mikrofone in irgendeiner form
zusammenhängen also bildung dabei
wirtschaft wie kommt man da wieder raus
hinterher und das klima thema haben
viele gesagt das war vor anderthalb
jahren für mich noch das absolute top
thema aber jetzt im moment geht es darum
die pandemie zu beenden
dann sage ich an der stelle ganz kurz
danke zu dir simon wir sind gleich
wieder da und gucken mal zu den jungs
rüber wie weit sie sich denn durch
geklickt haben bei welcher frage seid
ihr denn gerade durch mund zu mund
befriedigt sehen
das ist sensationell der genau frage 10
wäre eine über die ich gerne mit euch
gesprochen hätte und zwar bei der
besetzung von führungspositionen in
landeseigenen betrieben soll eine
verbindliche frauenquote gelten
was sagt ihr dazu fünf dürfen also
selbst hat ja auch mit diskriminierung
zu tun und das ist wirklich immer noch
so ist dass männer dann diese domäne
haben und die holen sich ja auch nicht
raus aus diesen positionen das heißt
wenn es schade ist es tatsächlich dass
es nur so geht dass man die quote
braucht es nicht so ausgeglichen ist das
nicht um darum geht was man kann oder
was man gelernt hat sondern dass man da
eine quote braucht aber wenn es so sein
soll dann muss es finde ich so sein und
ich glaube sind nur 30 prozent oder
knapp 29 prozent in führungsfunktionen
deutschland 13 frauen und gestalten
ungleichgewicht und das finde ich muss
man ausgleichen
martin was meinst du ja sehr cool dass
lukas werk mehrzahl hatte weil die hat
mir so ein bisschen gefehlt aber ich
stimme ihm gleich
komplett zu ist es natürlich sehr
wünschen wünschenswert wenn es keine
quote also wenn keine quote notwendig
wäre aber so wie es aktuell hält auch
sie braucht man eine und deswegen bin
ich da auch absolut dafür
okay das sind von beiden männern ein
ganz klares ja dann würde ich das auch
ganz einfach so hier eingeben und zur
nächsten frage kommen und zwar ist das
frage 11 der konfessionelle
religionsunterricht an öffentlichen
schulen in baden württemberg soll
abgeschafft werden was ist eure meinung
dazu wir sehen die themen gehen echt so
ein bisschen durcheinander
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wer
beim wahlomat sich um die reihenfolge
kümmert was das system dahinter ist ob
es ein system gibt oder nach welche
relevanz die abfolge ausgesucht wird
aber wir richten uns einfach nach der
abfolge wie sie vorgegeben ist und dann
sind wir eben jetzt beim thema religion
was sagt ihr dazu ja ich selbst hatte
keinen religionsunterricht in auf meiner
schule ab der 89
unglaublich war ich dann im
ethik-unterricht und schwanz immer so
ein bisschen schade dass ich dann von
macht so ein bisschen getrennt war was
quasi dass religionsunterricht angehen
und nicht erst wünschenswert werden die
klasse in der hinsicht zusammen bleibt
und ist einfach ein religionsunterricht
gibt der sich nicht nur spezifischen
eine religion kümmert sondern ebenso mit
miteinander fördert in deutschland man
sich alle regionen der religionen
einfach zusammen anschaut die
gemeinsamkeiten findet vielleicht und so
eben in der klasse halte ich es mit
miteinander schon früh stärkt was
verschiedene kulturen auch angeht
deswegen abschaffen ja aber vielleicht
dann rüber zu einem gemeinsamen
ethikunterricht das finde ich glaube ich
ganz cool ich habe noch mal nachgelesen
tatsächlich ist dieser bekenntnis
gebundene religionsunterricht sozusagen
ein relikt von 1919 aus der weimarer
kirchenrechts verfassung als noch mehr
als 90 prozent der deutschen einer
christlichen religion angehört haben und
dann ist er im grundgesetz gelandet
artikel 7 absatz 3 garantiert diesen
unterricht nur es ist halt heute so dass
nur
noch 53 prozent der deutschen
katholische oder evangelische sind vier
prozent sind muslime 4 prozent sind
mitglieder anderer religionen und knapp
38 prozent haben gar keine
religionszugehörigkeit koste was sagst
du ist das gehört das abgeschafft soll
man das ändern und wenn ja wie sie haben
also manchen hat sie auch schon gesagt
du auch im endeffekt ist es nicht mehr
zeitgemäß was da unterrichtet wird ich
sehe das jetzt auch noch mal aus einer
schulischen perspektive also ich selber
habe im religionsunterricht mandalas
gemalt und habe mir geschichten angehört
und ich weiß ich weiß jetzt einfach dass
es viel wichtigere sachen gibt die man
einfach in der schule unterrichten kann
und ich weiß nicht ob man die zeit nicht
anders nutzen kann und es geht ja um den
konfessionellen unterricht das heißt
eklig da werde ich auch kompletter für
ich finde es auch wichtig unabhängig
davon ob ich gläubig bin oder nicht aber
ich finde halt alle perspektiven wichtig
dass man noch alle regionen man
mitbekommt und dass man die bei mal
reinschnuppern kann
aber wenn man wirklich so getrieben in
eine richtung ich meine ich wurde
getauft aber ich habe mich ja nicht
dafür entschieden daran zu glauben im
endeffekt und werd dann aber zehn jahre
lang durchgeschleust und muss dann auch
quasi den arbeiten darüber schreiben was
was vielleicht an dinge die ich da gar
nicht dran glaubt grundsätzlich will ich
jetzt also grundsätzlich finde ich ja
den grundgedanken von religionen gration
der katholische religion zum beispiel
auch in der getauften wagen gar nicht
schlecht da geht es darum gute dinge
aber ob das jetzt schulisch so zeitgemäß
ist sondern dass in den kontext passt
weiß ich nicht da würde ich jetzt sagen
ich würde eher neutral dazu jetzt
abstimmen weil ich mir da wahrscheinlich
auch noch mehr angucken müsste was denn
die alternative wäre aber ja er dann
abschaffen als lassen und das war sie in
ethik auswahl
ok dürfte ich dann weil martin quasi
gesagt ja gesagt hat ja soll abgeschafft
werden ist das okay für euch wenn ich an
der stelle einfach mal zustimme dass
oder soll ich kann doch einfach die
these überspringen so ist ja egal kommt
ja jetzt sowieso nicht darauf an was
hier rauskommt bin ja eher gespannt was
dann bei euch raus kommt ich überspringe
das und geh mal weiter zum thema bildung
so zu sagen da gibt es die frage 14 in
baden württemberg soll es mehr
gemeinschaftsschulen geben
cosmo und das ist natürlich gerade für
dich ein riesenthema weil du ja ganz nah
dran bist
lehrer ja finde ich gut
grundsätzlich sei der grundgedanke dass
auch die schwächeren den stärkeren also
die stärkere den schwächeren helfen und
umgekehrt weil es gibt der stärken und
schwächen in verschiedenen formen und in
verschiedenen fächern und ich finde auch
dass man einfach länger zusammen bleibt
grundsätzlich in der schule weil man ja
auch freundschaften aufbaut und weil man
da bindung einfach auch zu läuten
aufbaut und bei mir war das selbst so
ich war selber erst auf der hauptschule
weil ich da hingeschickt wurde von den
lehrern kam dann auf die realschule und
zum glück aber wenn ich das nicht
geschafft hätte ich fast gar keine
chance mehr gehabt aufzusteigen
so hat man halt man es gibt ja
spätentwickler ich bin so einer und wenn
man halt erst so nach der siebten achten
klasse checkt worum es wirklich reich
schule geht dann hat man da eben noch
die chance dann den realschulabschluss
zu machen sonst wenn steam anderen
systemen als hauptschule realschule
gymnasium abläuft so war es bei mir
zumindest dass ich mich da schnell
verloren gefühlt hätte also klares
statement für mehr gemeinschaftsschulen
von cosmo martin was ist deine meinung
ich stimme ihm zu also der grundgedanke
ist natürlich extrem wünschenswert ich
stelle mir nur die frage quasi ob dann
auch wirklich die stärkeren in der
schule den schwächeren helfen oder ob
sie sich vielleicht langweilt und sich
auch in ihren fähigkeiten nicht
irgendwie gefördert fühlen
ich weiß nicht es gibt ja schon aktuell
gemeinschaftsschulen es wäre jetzt
natürlich interessant zu wissen wie die
allgemein angenommen werden wie sind die
ergebnisse wie wieviel empfinden die
schüler dass ich habe die erfahrung zum
beispiel nicht gemacht aber an sich der
grundgedanke ist natürlich sehr sehr
cool
dh von euch beiden an der stelle ein
klares jahr richtig so dann stimme ich
hier mal zu bin erstaunt oder was heißt
erstaunt also mir fällt auf jeden fall
auf dass ihr euch bei den meisten sachen
bisher einig seit bin gespannt ob es da
an der einen oder anderen stelle noch
noch ein bisschen kontroverse gibt und
wird euro
ja bitte ja ich finde einfach so das
sind diese fragen also irgendwie geht es
gerade viel umso normalen
menschenverstand so weil keine ahnung
gesamtschulen ja ja ist ja alles gut
positiv oder negativ
ich finde das sehr sehr schwierig
so eine eigene meinung zu finden weil es
tatsächlich nur ja oder nein gibt und
bisher waren uns halt fragen wie finde
ich auch gerade in unserem alter hat uns
ansprechen auch aus schule angeht
deswegen glaube ich so laufen wieder so
ein bisschen synchron ja ja klar und das
ist ja auch genau das ziel von wahlomat
dass man gar nicht leute anspricht die
sowieso davon ausgehen dass sie alles
wissen und alles schon beantworten
können sondern dass man halt einfach
auch mal selber drüber nachdenkt wie ist
denn meine haltung dazu
also dass man sich manche fragen stellt
die man sonst immer so mit krieg wenn
man nachrichten guckt oder im internet
unterwegs ist oder diese auf dem
tagesgeschäft behandelt werden dann sagt
man regt man sich auch unser ok der eine
oder andere hat jetzt aber irgendwie
eine schräge position immer was
eigentlich meine eigene haltung dazu was
wie würde ich das denn entscheiden
von daher finde ich das sehr cool dass
ihr da gerade ein bisschen uns teilhaben
lasse wie wie eure meinung dazu ist dann
klickt euch doch gerne mal einfach ein
paar fragen weiter durch und ich würde
das thema bildung noch mal an simon
pfanzelt weitergeben nach stuttgart ins
studio und zwar frage 21 würde ich mal
an wählen denn die hat quasi simon mit
der frage nach bildung und der frage
nach digitalisierung zu tun in baden
württemberg soll es ein eigenständiges
ministerium für digitalisierung geben
ich weiß nicht ob es diese frage gegeben
hätte simon bevor corona war aber jetzt
nachdem viele eltern und viele schüler
ein echt hartes jahr und viele
lehrerinnen und lehrer vor allem auch
ein echter hartes jahr hinter sich haben
stellt sich die frage nach
digitalisierung und bildung ja ganz
besonders wie sieht das in baden
württemberg aus ob es ein ministerium
geben wird das hängt natürlich davon ab
wer am ende mit einander koaliert die
cdu und die fdp fordern das ganz stark
die anderen haben da eher skeptische
haltung im grunde glaube ich dass in den
nächsten fünf jahren sich jedes ressort
mit dem thema digitalisierung
beschäftigen werden muss all das geht um
wirtschaft es geht um landwirtschaft in
der justiz ist das ein thema im
tourismus aber eben natürlich auch in
den schulen und dass da wirklich dass
ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist in den
letzten jahren das hat eben diese corona
pandemie wirklich offen gelegt
welche rolle spielt es denn dass die
spitzenkandidatin der cdu gleichzeitig
bildungsministerin war oder ist das hat
in diesem wahlkampf eine enorm große
rolle gespielt ich habe auch susanne
eisenmann mal begleitet bei einem
wahlkampfauftritt die flyer verteilt das
hat keine fünf minuten gedauert bis dann
der aufgebrachte mutter bei ihr war und
sie mit diesem ganzen problemen
konfrontiert hat die cdu
spitzenkandidatin ist da irgendwie in
diesem wahlkampf so einem kreuzfeuer
gelandet es gibt eltern die wollen die
schulen so schnell wie möglich wieder
öffnen es gibt die anderen die sind eher
vorsichtig wollen sie zu haben
dann gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
interessen von schülern und lehrern und
da war frau eisenmann von der cdu schon
in der schwierigen position und ihr
gegner der ministerpräsident kretschmann
hat das auch geschickt genutzt er hat
immer wieder auf diese zuständigkeit von
frau eisenmann bei diesem schulbereich
verwiesen bei den großen duellen die es
gab zum beispiel und zwar nicht nur bei
der digitalisierung auch was masken
beschaffung angeht oder was test
strategien für schulen angeht hat er
eben immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
dass frau eisenmann dafür zuständig ist
und also auch für die defizite zuständig
ist
hier kommt gerade eine frage über den
chat von chris hahn über youtube die
unterschiede zwischen den parteien sind
minimal ich nehme an das ist eine
globale frage die sich jetzt nicht nur
auf die bildung bezieht aber kannst du
das bestätigen ist man da in vielen
sachen einer meinung oder geht da in die
richtige richtung oder gab es da
tatsächlich auch polarisierung
vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein beispiel
aus dem bildungsbereich wo man wirklich
sagen kann 'die liegen ganz weit
auseinander was die haltung angeht
beim bildungsbereich kann ich das jetzt
nicht sagen wenn wir vielleicht noch mal
auf das klima thema zurückkommen über
das wir vorher gesprochen haben
zum beispiel beim tempolimit da gibt es
eine klare abgrenzungen das sind spd
grüne und die linkspartei sind für so
ein tempolimit die cdu die afg und die
fdp sind dagegen da ist es relativ klar
bei diesem anderen thema das wir hatten
den verbrennungsmotor da ist es nicht so
eindeutig da sind sich irgendwie alle
einig dass man irgendwie im
transformationsprozess der
automobilindustrie braucht aber wie und
auf welchem weg das ist nicht so ganz
klar und wenn so ein konkretes datum
gibt vorher war das jahr 2000
35 glaube ich da drücken sich doch die
meisten parteien sich da so wirklich
definitiv fest zu legen hier im autoland
baden-württemberg der im autoland und
innovationsland und damit auch
bildungsstandort simon und dann schauen
wir noch mal wie eine lehrerin aus baden
württemberg die letzten monate erlebt
hat ihr habt für youtube ein paar
interviews gemacht richtig cool eclipse
und das geworden die adresse können wir
auch gerne in die kommentare schreiben
kann man sich sehr gut angucken zu
verschiedenen themen auch zur cannabis
freigabe zum beispiel oder zur
entkriminalisierung von geringen
cannabis mengen und dieser eine lehrerin
die hat vor allem in großen wunsch an
die politik das schauen wir uns mal aber
wir machen das jetzt deutsch mein liebes
kind
wir waren bei der einrichtung und bei
der suche von einem
kommunikationsplattform sicherlich auf
uns gestellt haben da viele eigene
arbeitsstunden reingesteckt wir müssen
jetzt das was wir gelernt haben mit in
die zukunft nehmen ist nicht wieder
weglegen mit zur seite tun und sagen ich
habe nur noch mal eine grüne tafel
sondern herausfinden wie wir beides
umsetzen können ich glaube den schulen
lasso seite zu stellen wer wahnsinnig
wichtig also hier jemanden zu haben der
vielleicht auch mehrere schulen betreut
das wäre sicherlich etwas das uns auf
dem weg der digitalisierung helfen
könnte
damit sind wir wieder beim thema schule
kostet und martin ich würde gerne noch
zwei fragen mit dazu nehmen zudem zu dem
bildungsbereich also digitalisierung ist
ein riesenthema aber frage 23 zum
beispiel ist das mittagessen soll für
alle schülerinnen und schüler an
baden-württembergischen schulen
kostenlos sein und frage 26 ist beim
wechsel auf die weiterführende schule
soll die empfehlung der
grundschullehrerinnen und
grundschullehrer verbindlich sein das
sind zwar jetzt viele fragen auf einmal
aber vielleicht können wir es irgendwie
ein bisschen kompakt durcharbeiten
zwingende empfehlungen ja oder nein
kostenloses mittagessen ja oder nein
also mit
dem mittagessen ist schon wieder so eine
frage wo man also welcher wer drückt
jetzt auf nein also wir haben wir gar
keine auflistungen das wurde wo das geld
herkommt oder wo das dann wieder
weggenommen wird dafür
deswegen würde ich da ich bin jetzt
sogar glaube ich sicher dass martin auch
das wählen würde ein kostenloses
mittagessen klingt er im ersten sind
schon mal gut denn ich weiß dass auch
einfach von der schule dass viele kinder
einfach sich auch schlecht ernähren ist
weil sie wahrscheinlich auch und ich
sehe dass das einfach billige sachen
sind das ist ja gar nicht das budget
liege meint weil sie schlecht sich auch
nicht mehr leisten können aber ich finde
so eine gesunde und gute ernährung und
ich halt sehr wichtig und massa 26
beim wechsel auf weiterführende schule
ja weil da weiß habe ich ja vorhin
erklärt ich wurde von meinen lehrern
eingestuft auf die hauptschule und meine
familie hat das überhaupt nicht so
empfunden hatten dann aber irgendwie
keine chance zu sagen lasst uns doch mal
auf die wertstellung versuchen weil ich
war dann quasi schon so eingestuft und
eine schublade und deswegen finde ich es
wichtig dass man das vielleicht zusammen
entscheidet natürlich sehen die lehrer
sich täglich und und kennen sich
natürlich auch das natürlich auch
wichtig die einstufung aber ich finde
man sollte trotzdem mit den eltern
absprechen und so einen mittelweg finden
hat sie jetzt auch nicht nur eltern weil
dann gibt es auch eltern geschicken halt
ihr kind aufs gymnasium in der hoffnung
dass es dann halt irgendwann mal
studiert obwohl völlig überfordert ist
aber so ein mittelding zwischen lehrern
und eltern fertig so die richtige lösung
hier gibt es ja in den kommentaren
relativ viele reaktionen zum thema
schule aber auch vor allem zum thema
schulform eli schreibt er über youtube
ich war der hauptschule und habe
trotzdem fach abitur geschafft
gemeinschaftsschulen braucht man nicht
und einer rate mal wer schreibt über
youtube das dreigliedrige schulsystem
ist sehr bewährt martin du nochmal
kostenloses mittagessen ja oder nein und
empfehlungen verbindlich ja oder nein
bayern zum beispiel macht das ja so
rheinland pfalz macht das nicht um mal
ein zwei nachbar bundesländer zu gucken
also ich bin auch hier wieder sehr
ähnlich mit lukas oder eigentlich
wirklich ähnlich so eine verpflichtende
grundschulempfehlung die man dann für
die weiterführende bekommt wenn ich
ein bisschen schwachsinnig also sollte
immer in einem austausch zwischen
lehrern aber auch eltern quasi kommen
sowie lukas gesagt hat wenn man einmal
auf einmal abgestempelt wird das verbaut
so ein bisschen auch die komplette
zukunft und das ist ja überhaupt nicht
wünschenswert und auch kostenloses
mittagessen für alle schüler finde ich
wäre super wir natürlich auch
interessant zu wissen ob dieses
mittagessen dann auch qualitativ
hochwertig wäre ich persönlich muss auch
zugeben ich habe früher in der
mittagspause einfach googlen welchen
oder chips gekauft weil es
wahrscheinlich nicht die beste ernährung
hätten wir da vielleicht ein angebot auf
der schule gehabt hätte ich das
wahrscheinlich auch gerne in anspruch
genommen und im besten fall könnte man
sogar die schüler vielleicht in einem
fach oder ein paar unterrichtsstunden
auch beiseite nehmen und sich direkt
darum kümmern dass die schüler erfahren
was ist jetzt genau gute gesunde
ernährung wie ernährt man sich gesund
und es dann am besten halt verbinden mit
einem kostenlosen mittagessen kann ich
super
also wir zeigt dass die einzige frage
die man mit ja nein oder vielleicht
beantworten kann ist schon immer gewesen
willst du mit mir gehen aber nicht die
verwaltung macht stellt weil hier ist es
echt schwer mit ja oder nein oder
neutral zu antworten
ich würde gerne bevor ich euch bittet
quasi alle fragen bis zum ende
durchzuklicken damit wir dann auch am
ende
endergebnis haben wenn ihr das dann
teilen wollt wendig ist auch überhaupt
kein thema darum soll es ja gar nicht
gehen aber vorher würde ich gerne noch
eine frage mit euch klären die wir
übersprungen haben
und zwar gab es auch die frage im
wahlomat die sich darauf bezieht zum
beispiel ob die polizei anlasslose
kontrollen einfach so machen können soll
ja oder nein also ganz anderes thema hat
jetzt mit dem thema bildung gar nichts
zu tun
die quasi mehr so in dem bereich innere
sicherheit polizei
wie ist denn ihre haltung dazu wenn wir
das vielleicht bevor wir den sack hier
zu machen noch besprechen können
also man möchte ja kein okay kosten ich
lass dir gern den vortritt
wer anfängt weil das bild bei mir auch
so ein bisschen versetzt es deswegen
mache ich dann fange ich gerne an also
ohne verdacht konnte
ich will ja keinen schwarzen peter
irgendwie zu schieben aber das hört sich
schon so ein bisschen an dass die
polizei falls sie denn jemanden sieht
der jetzt sage ich mal in richtung
kriminelle aussieht und also es geht in
eine ganz eklige richtung finde ich
deswegen würde ich das absolut nicht für
gut heißen wenn da einfach willkürlich
ohne verdacht jemand kontrolliert werden
kann
ja das ist das fand ich auf jeden fall
nicht gut hast du was das du dazu hast
du da vielleicht auch schon erfahrungen
gemacht oder wie ist das bei dir ja also
zuhauf tatsächlich salz in der stadt
wenn man da unterwegs ist irgendwie
abend und trat auch in koppl dabei denke
auch schwarz ist und man dann halt
einfach kontrolliert wird und ich weiß
gar nicht wie die aktuelle gesetzeslage
ist ob man dann ein anfangsverdacht
braucht aber den der anfangsverdacht den
kriegt man ja irgendwoher man sagt hier
sind komisch gelaufen dem rom
geschrieben ist ja auch egal
aber man fühlt sich halt immer
verdächtig und wenn sie schon gesetz
gibt was das erlaubt dann entsteht
irgendwann so nicht willkür und man kann
diese leute das ist ja auch schikanen
man wird er schikaniert oder zum
beispiel wenn ich auto fahre ich will
auch wirklich niemand über einen kamm
schert
aber ich weiß es einfach auch wenn ich
auto fahre und mich sieht niemand im
streifen ich werde angehalten so da geht
es halt um schubladendenken da gibt es
vielleicht auch irgendwo eine quote ist
weiß es nicht aber das fühlt sich als
betroffener einfach man fühlt sich als
mensch zweiter klasse wenn man weiß man
sieht verdächtig aus wie auch martin ist
gerade schon meinte es gibt eine sehr
sehr ekel gericht und wenn es dann
gesetzestechnisch schon lassen wird und
man darf das dann gibt es ja noch mehr
ausufern grundsätzlich muss man auch
sagen wahrscheinlich ist schon so dass
das sieht auch einen blick dafür haben
wahrscheinlich aber das kann eben nicht
sein also wie kann in einer mitte zum
beispiel unterscheiden von wirklich
kriminellen aus halt auf grund also wenn
wir gleich aussehen der kann das ja gar
nicht und trotzdem werde ich dann immer
angehalten und das also finde ich
furchtbar wenn du wirklich glaube in
bayern ist es schon so dass vor allem
natürlich auch ein thema was über baden
württemberg hinaus geht und und nicht
nur eine landespolitische frage ist
sondern auch eine bundespolitische frage
und ich danke euch an der stelle für die
für die beantwortung dieser echt
schwierigen frage und wird gerne noch
auch weil wir sowieso schon gnadenlos
drüber gehauen haben aber weil ich echt
spannend finde die die anmerkung von
einem user nahmen die klinke des herrn
aufgreifen der schreibt auf youtube ganz
ehrlich die tendenz der sendung war doch
vorhersehbar und er sagt dass man sich
vor frage 15 drücken würde
ebenfalls frage 15 und machen das würde
ich sagen das machen wir gerne frage
nochmal die klinken des herrn genau also
sehr sehr interessant wäre natürlich
auch wie ihre oder deine position ist
schreibt doch das gerne einfach auch in
den chat wie deine haltung ist aber
immer bitte sachlich bleiben
das nichtvergessen frage 15 für alle die
den wahlomat jetzt nicht auswendig
gelernt haben ist flüchtlinge sollen
ihren schutzstatus verlieren wenn sie in
ihr herkunftsland reisen ja oder nein
wer möchte anfangen ich kann anfangen
bitte also da biss mich tatsächlich auch
mal kurz was heißt eingelesen hat mir
das angeguckt weil so die frage scheint
ja eigentlich ziemlich einfach super
also nicht einfach zu beantworten wenn
man sie nicht
ich glaube es geht darum dass
flüchtlinge quasi ihren status besitzen
und als flüchtlinge gelten weil es eben
in ihrem heimatland verfolgt werden
und da soll halt ein gesetz her dass die
nicht mehr ins heimatland dürfen weil
wenn die einst heimat wann gehen können
dann kann es nicht sein dass er da
hingeht verfolgt werden ich finde das
ist ein sehr sehr komplexes thema und
das tatsächlich sehr sehr schwierig
direkt zu beantworten
aber so grundsätzlich wenn man es so
primitiv beantragte denken was ja
eigentlich stimmt wenn man schon folgt
wird und geflüchtet ist von irgendwo
dann kann ich dann nicht noch mal dazu
ein geburtstag oder was weiß ich wofür
hinfliegen
ich glaube einfach dass sind zu komplexe
themen deswegen findet machen die in
wahlomat halt auch überhaupt keinen sinn
weil wenn man wenn man das beantworten
will muss man sich wirklich einlesen und
ich weiß nicht mal ob die die wirklich
sich damit beschäftigen dann eine
richtige meinung dazu haben oder ob das
halt insgesamt so komplex ist dass es
kein richtig und kein falsch gibt ja und
ganz ehrlich so wie du sagst cossu ist
es soweit ich das verstanden habe denn
laut dem bundesamt für flüchtlinge gibt
es nach
wie vor für reisen von anerkannten
flüchtlingen kein geregeltes
gesetzliches verfahren also die frage
ist tatsächlich so komplex dass selbst
der gesetzgeber noch keine schlüssige
antwort darauf gefunden hat martin was
sagst du dazu ja wie lukas muss man das
definitiv sehr differenziert sehen und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen auf die
dauer schauen
ich habe mich da auch natürlich ein
bisschen eingelesen weil mich das auch
sehr interessiert hat wie es aktuell
hand gehabt wird ich finde eben wenn man
seine familie im heimatland zurück
lassen muss und da irgendetwas
vorgefallen ist dann sollten sie sich
nicht nicht auf den weg nach hause
machen können allein vor der angst dass
man seinen schutzstatus verliert oder
wenn man dann zu einer beerdigung nach
hause möchte um vielleicht auch
traurigerweise seinen elternteil das
letzte mal zu sehen
dann sollte es nicht irgendwie vorkommen
dass die sich sorgen machen müssen dass
sie dann auch noch ihren schutzstatus
verlieren deswegen ist es ist es sehr
komplex und auch schwierig dann aufgrund
seiner thesen balance direkt zustimmen
zu können oder eben auch nicht
vielen dank für die sehr differenzierten
meinung die ihr dazu habt und die ja
auch noch mal dazu anregen über viele
sachen noch mal nachzudenken
dann klickt ihr euch gerne in aller ruhe
mal zu ende und ich gehe noch mal zu
simon ens landesschule zurück und zwar
mit frage 27 simon die querdenken
gruppierung soll weiterhin vom landesamt
für verfassungsschutz baden-württemberg
beobachtet werden ohne an der stelle die
frage zu sehr zu vertiefen
simon aber baden württemberg ist
natürlich das land in dem querdenken
gegründet wurde das land das auch corona
anti corona mäßig echt viel kritik
erfahren hat wie wie kann man das
zusammenfassen wie es baden württemberg
durch diese pandemie gekommen bisher
es hätte ein bisschen davon ab mit wem
man sich darüber unterhält
allgemein kann man sagen dass die
querdenker leiser geworden sind sie
haben sich zum teil auch aufgespalten
ist der recht diffuse bewegung
mittlerweile was die korona bewältigung
angeht würde ich sagen ist baden
württemberg genauso gut oder genauso
schlecht durch diese zeit bekommen wie
andere bundesländer auch es gab hier
zwar immer mal wieder so pilotprojekte
es würde ja zum beispiel diese tests
strategien tübingen sehr berühmt wo es
dann wirklich gelungen ist die fälle in
den pflege- und altenheim sehr
einzudämmen
aber das waren es keine dinge die
landesweit ausgerollt gewesen wären dann
schauen wir uns mal gemeinsam an wie das
politbarometer
da die projektion für die landtagswahl
hat wenn nächsten sonntag wahl wäre was
ja nun in diesem fall auch so ist sieht
man nicht weiß nicht ob du das gesehen
kann es deshalb lese ich gerade mal vor
also die letzten zahlen vom
politbarometer sind wären 35 prozent für
die grünen 24 für die cdu elf für die
afg 10 für die spd 10 für die fdp drei
für die linke und 7 für die anderen
wenn du die zahlen siehst was würdest du
sagen wer profitiert am ehesten von der
pandemie und wer kann gewinnen
also die grünen profitieren ganz
offensichtlich das hängt auch damit
zusammen dass wir durch diese befragung
auch feststellen konnten dass diese
pandemie eben das entscheidende thema
ist und die grünen jedenfalls aus sicht
der wähler die befragt wurden da am
meisten kompetenz vorzuweisen hat es
gibt allerdings eine kleine unbekannte
würde ich sagen wenn wir jetzt auch den
sonntag gucken denn diese pandemie
müdigkeit die man überall so spürt da
wissen wir nicht so genau wie die sich
dann wirklich auf das wahlergebnis
auswirkt ob es dann noch bewegung gibt
können wir nicht sagen im moment geben
die zahlen eigentlich nicht her dass
selbst in irgendeiner form eine
protestpartei kommt die jetzt
viel stärke noch in den landtag einzieht
und dieses thema zu ihrem macht aber es
war zum beispiel 2016 so bei der letzten
landtagswahl
das war die erste landtagswahl nach der
flüchtlingskrise und dann war plötzlich
die afg mit 15
hier im landtag und jetzt haben wir hier
in baden württemberg wieder die erste
landtagswahl in der pandemie und ob es
da ähnliche parallelitäten gibt es wird
wirklich spannend werden dann sonntag
herr simon spannend wird auch wie das
für euch als korrespondenten reporter
journalisten berichterstatter wird
welche hygiene konzepte gelten wie könnt
ihr berichten wie wie sieht der sonntag
aus du wirst ja auch dabei sein
wie ist diese erste landtagswahl in
einer pandemie aus eurer sicht
es ist gefühlt alles anders also schon
dass man eben diese klassischen
wahlpartys nicht mehr hat wo man dann
jubelnde menschen sieht und andere die
wegen ihrer partei völlig am boden
zerstört sind all das gibt es nicht mehr
es gibt sehr strenge gehende konzepte
wir können uns auch alle vor ort testen
lassen
es wird eine strenge masken pflicht
geben also im grunde die dinge an die
wir uns in den letzten monaten wenn wir
drehen waren ohnehin schon gewöhnt haben
ok dann sind wir sehr gespannt wie am
sonntag der wahlsonntag laufen wird ich
selber wird auch nach stuttgart fahren
können und als reporterin berichten ich
bin auch sehr gespannt
also dann bis am sonntag wir werden uns
wahrscheinlich nicht sehen und wenn dann
nur mit abstand weil es tatsächlich eine
schwierige kiste wird am sonntag 7 und
vielen vielen herzlichen dank dass du
hier im stream dabei warst und aus
landespolitischer korrespondent in sicht
erläutert hast wie dieser wahlkampf
gelaufen ist und den ausblick auf den
sonntag gesagt hast vielen dank simon
und dann gehen wir noch mal zurück zu
den beiden die jetzt hoffentlich ich
denke ihr seid durch genau ihr seid
beide durch und jetzt ist natürlich die
große frage wenn man sich dadurch klickt
dann kann man nochmal die parteien die
positionen gewicht ein bisschen
schwerpunkte verteilen
und dann am ende kommt eine partei raus
ihr müsst jetzt gar nicht sagen welche
partei rausgekommen ist aber was mich
interessiert vor allem ist ob ich das
ergebnis überrascht habt oder ob ihr
damit schon gerechnet habe es sind
definitiv teilweise überraschungen dabei
andererseits befindet sich jetzt auch
eine partei bei mir ganz unten also mit
geringster die einstimmung überhaupt
nicht überrascht bin muss ich auch
ehrlich sein ich sehe es auch immer so
ein bisschen bisschen differenzierter
einfach man sollte jetzt diese
potenziale nicht unbedingt als indiz
nehmen dass man auch diese partei
unbedingt wählen muss und ich finde es
auch extrem spannend wenn man bei diesen
nochmal durchblick uns anschaut was die
parteien darauf geschrieben haben und
wird nun definitiv ein bisschen schlauer
aber es ist eine super orientierung
findet kassel wie es bei dir tatsächlich
ist ein bisschen überraschend dass da
eine partei oben steht die ich jetzt
grundsätzlich gar nicht ganz so hoch
gesetzt hat ich glaube die partei ganz
unten ist auch wie bei martin ist
ansprechend beim nächstes dfb und ganz
oben ist wirklich eine partei die ich
dann richtig gesetzt sind aber
tatsächlich finde ich es auch extrem
schwierig sich weil die haben alle
irgendwie was gut ist und was schlecht
ist grundsätzlich ist es glaube ich auch
in deutschland so ein ding das man auch
wenn man in dem beruf drinsteckt und wo
es halt dann am geld geht dann
entscheidet man sich eher für die punkte
oder die partei die jene punkte
anspricht die einem selber vorteile
bringen und ich finde das halt irgendwie
schade dass es dann im endeffekt gar
nicht mehr um so eine allgemeine
politische haltung geht sondern halt wo
kriege ich die meisten vorteile jetzt
raus und man als privatmensch aber man
hat ja auch irgendwie gefühlt immer
schon so eine partei im hinterkopf aber
dann wenn man dann durchgeht und gucken
was die eigentlich auch stehen da geht
man sich eigentlich kann ich da schon 0
stehen ja ist immer wieder immer wieder
schwierig habt ihr denn schon briefwahl
gemacht also habt ihr schon gewählt oder
geht ihr am am sonntag wählen und macht
euer kreuzchen
ich werde am sonntag hingehen ich habe
meinen brief schon rausgesucht damit ich
auf jeden fall die adresse nicht
verpasst 8 bis 18 uhr habe ich auch
schon gesehen also ich werde definitiv
selbst hingehen mit der
wahlbenachrichtigung in der hand und
allem was dazu gehört alles klar und du
kannst
ich werde auch gehen ich habe glaube ich
es noch nie doch einmal weiß glaube ich
nicht da ich hab mal wird auf jeden fall
ich finde es auch immer so eine man
zelebriert das irgendwie ich weiß nicht
mal guckt sich doch immer auch sich die
leute an und denkt so was will der jetzt
und jetzt sollen wir ganz spannend ich
vergessen es innerhalb der vier jahre
immer wieder wie es abläuft dann kommt
nicht wieder wie ein golf wischte das
jetzt zum ersten mal sieht an und freue
mich dann immer drüber
ja ich werde hingehen und damit meine
stimme abgeben
dann würde ich euch ganz zum schluss
noch bitten auf die den kommentar von
einer userin zu antworten claudia braun
schreibt über youtube ich würde gar
nicht wählen gehen
denn das kleinere übel zu wählen es auch
nicht besser wurden jemals irgendwelche
wichtigen wahlversprechen gehalten was
wäre wenn gar keiner wählen geht könnt
ihr claudia braun überzeugen doch wählen
zu gehen warum findet ihr es richtig
eure stimme abzugeben
sie heißt claudia hauen nicht mehr
claudia braun ich weiß ist also das muss
aber auch schon oft erklärt dass gar
keine stimme abgeben das macht sich
bezahlt habe auch gerade erklärt dass
ich auch probleme damit habe das
richtige zu finden aber wenn man in
einer demokratie lebt und dann sind auch
auf die menschen die die klappe ganz
weit auf reisen aber dann nicht wählen
gehen und es passt halt nicht dazu klar
man kann sagen ich habe nur eine kleine
stimme aber wenn man nicht mal benutzt
wie kann ich mich dann überhaupt
beschweren oder mach halt was dagegen
aber sich generell gegen eine wahl zu
stellen finde ich dass gerade wenn man
das glück hat und ich weiß auch von
vielen kumpels drauf und von mir selber
dass es einfach länder gibt indes das
wahlrecht nicht gibt und das sterben
menschen dafür und kämpfen dafür und
wenn man das dann nicht wahrnimmt ist
dass das eine chance hast du danke für
deinen schluss statement martin was hast
du kann ich mich eigentlich nur
anschließen also grundsätzlich ist ein
riesen privileg was wir hier haben das
sollte man definitiv wahrnehmen und
vielleicht noch zu den punkt sie meinte
ja was wäre wenn keiner wählen geht das
wird eben nicht der fall sein ich weiß
ganz genau wer auf jeden fall wählen
geht und wenn dann halt andere leute
nicht wählen
um dem entgegenzuwirken dann wird die
die macht die die dann bekommen über die
stimmen leider ein bisschen größer sein
deswegen kann ich nur dazu plädieren
geht wählen
macht euch schlau davor wen er wählen
möchte und nutzt euer privileg definitiv
martin koch ganz herzlichen dank dass
ihr dabei hat das ihr mitgemacht habe
das war für mich der längste leisten den
wir hier gemacht haben abgesehen von
irgendwelchen bund länder konferenz und
den wein corona die die sich echt in die
länge gezogen haben aber das hier hat
einfach nur spaß gemacht das war total
interessant die community ist echt
begeistert viele danken euch dafür auch
dass ihr das ihr mitgemacht habt und das
tue ich auch vielen dank an euch und
einen schönen abend euch noch unten
guten wahlsonntag am sonntag und ich
verabschiede mich an der stelle nicht
ohne zwei hinweise der eine ist nachher
gibt neue politbarometer zahlen mit
matthias fornoff im zdf heute journal
und dann natürlich auch auf der homepage
kann man sich die zahlen alle noch mal
anschauen und am sonntag gibt es nicht
nur im zdf-hauptprogramm eine
wahlsendung die ich ihnen und euch sehr
ans herz lege sondern auch hier auf zdf
live ab sind zdf heute live ist war es
doch zu lang zdf heute live ist am
sonntag mit dabei wenn in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
gewählt wird um 17 uhr geht's los und
dunhill bröckerhoff wird für euch da
sein
seit mit dabei bis dahin bis ich dann
wieder da bin